you will now be recorded no say are you
recording okay and yeah we do have kind
of I think a technical issue just with
like making sure that we have the
information out in advance so we are
going to be taking things kind of slow
and what we thought of is doing another
session just to kind of give everybody
an overview of the program next time
which would be August or sorry June and
the next Monday one second say okay yeah
can 8:00
okay so let's give this a couple more
minutes so that we can have everybody
join in the meantime what is the plan
for today we're just going to go over
the program what are we trying to
achieve in this program what are we
going to cover and then we can kind of
move forward and discuss some of the
materials and some of the dates for the
upcoming meetings and start planning how
to make this work for everyone so good
morning my name is Elia Brodsky I am
from Pine biotech and we have been
working together with the Louisiana
biomedical research network and to
establish this summer program the summer
program in bioinformatics is going to be
focused on working with next-generation
sequencing data and utilizing some of
the resources that we have put together
with LB RN to make this data insightful
and informative for your research
project the program has been open to all
of the LB RN primarily undergraduate
Institute participants I Quixote and
students and we are excited to have a
number of you join us this summer we are
still finalizing the details
about registration so that we know that
everybody who registered got information
on how to join these sessions and
unfortunately we didn't have too much
time to send out this information for
this session so like I mentioned already
we will be recording these sessions and
we will be sending you the recording in
a few days when it's complete as well as
sending in the materials and we will do
repeat of this session in a week from
now on July 8 and hopefully by that time
we will be able to reach everybody and
let everybody know about how to join and
how to benefit from all of this so we do
have your information so we know a
little bit about you that you know where
which University you're from a little
bit about your background why you wanted
to join this course and thank you for
providing us with that information but
we will also ask you to share a little
bit more about types of day that you're
working with and your experience so far
and how would you be interested in
benefiting from working together with us
over the next couple of months so let me
start from the very beginning because I
want to make sure that everybody is on
the same page about bioinformatics and
about what we will be doing so I will go
into a little bit of basics in the
beginning and then hopefully we will
quickly transition to the subject matter
of this program okay so bioinformatics
as you all know is an interdisciplinary
field that basically applies the
principles of statistics and computer
science to the domain of biology meaning
to answer biological questions to work
with biological data and to be able to
design experiments to be able to
interpret the data from these
experiments and to make our decisions
about biological
questions more meaningful so what in
that context I think it's very important
to understand that even though all of us
can be familiar with all of these
aspects of bioinformatics really we're
talking about a team effort most of the
time and so a lot of times in successful
bioinformatics projects you would have
people that have deep domain expertise
in each one of these areas working
together to address one bigger problem
and because of that I think it's
important to all be able to speak the
same language somebody is going to have
maybe more domain expertise in one area
of biology where the project is focused
somebody might have more experience in
statistics or utilizing the
computational kind of infrastructure
that is really needed to address some of
these questions but and for some people
that also requires innovation in those
computational tools but ultimately I
think the most successful bioinformatics
projects come out of these fruitful
collaborations between experts in these
different domains another reason why
it's important to kind of establish a
common language between these different
domains or areas is because we see the
need to really connect these various
aspects of how how data can impact
specifically biology and or even
biomedical projects which is more of a
focus in this biomedical research
Network the Louisiana biomedical
research Network because the data Jana
is being generated and it's being
generated by technicians or by people
that work in labs and I think
understanding how this data is used and
understanding what types of data might
be informative to address the specific
question really helps the technicians
make sure that they record the specific
metadata that they deal with about the
data that they generate kind of be in
communication with the people downstream
and and ultimately generate more and
better data which is a critical need and
a lot of these projects also I think for
by informaticians for people that are
joining from a computer science
background I think the motivation there
you understand how the data is generated
why it is generated what are the
specific calls and how its going to be
used and so I think that to improve data
analysis to be able to image the data
better it is important to understand the
full process and that's what we're going
to try and cover on some of these
lectures I do want to ask for those of
you wanting to just mute the microphone
for now I will give you a chance to
speak as well a little bit later but for
now you should be able to have yes the
microphone muted thank you very much and
finally I think it's important to
understand that some of data insights
that we will generate the projects that
we work on and the insights that we
generate from this data is going to be
utilized in important decisions these
might be decisions about patience in the
long kind of term but these also will be
decisions about specific experiments and
so it's very important for us to
understand how this data and how the
insights are being utilized and what it
takes to get it to that level so I think
that's why this program is important for
different types of people people that
are students and work in labs or plan to
work in labs plan to be in research or
even industry at some point it's
important for people with a
computational background that will be
designing and developing new methods of
analysis or combining different methods
of analysis to take on larger projects
it's going to be very important for
people that use this insight in making
decisions about you know maybe
generating new types of data or setting
up a new set of experiments because they
need to kind of be familiar with what
methods are there to be able to extract
some insights from that data and what is
the value of those insights so the goal
of this program is going to be to really
start applying the bioinformatics tools
and methods to research problems so what
we will try to focus on is making sure
that everybody is familiar with how to
transfer your sequencing data onto the
server where you can run your pipelines
you can do your analysis different types
of data we'll discuss a few different
formats of data different formats of
course have different sizes and and then
we have a central repository that we've
created for this group where you'll be
able to upload your large datasets and
then we will show you how to start
utilizing that data to run some analysis
we will talk about quality control on
raw sequencing data so we'll be able to
run some preliminary analysis on the
length of reads and the coverage and
understand what these things mean and
why they are important for downstream
analysis we will talk about some
pre-processing and filtering some things
that are related to the preparation the
library prep and the preparation of the
data and understanding how the data was
prepared can improve our ability to
analyze this data and we will also talk
about just kind of planning how do we
approach different types of questions so
that how do we translate our
understanding of what we have to
practical steps and being able to have
everything that's needed to execute a
successful bioinformatics analysis in
the context of this program that is
going to be contacts going to be focused
on next-generation sequencing
and on RNA seek specifically we'll talk
about mapping those sequencing reads to
the ruffle relevant reference genome how
to cure genome how to make sure that
it's the right reference sometimes we
map on the genome sometimes we'll map on
the transcriptome so we will talk about
some of those things
finally after it's being mapped how do
we quantify the transcript abundance and
how do we estimate transcript expression
from that abundance different
normalization techniques and what do
they mean
how do they compare between themselves
and also how do we actually develop or
produce a table of expression that has
those numbers for each transcript and
then once that table is there we will
use different statistical analysis
methods to identify first of all
differential expression among samples
groups of samples conditions treatments
so we'll talk about some aspects of
p-values and different testing
techniques and how do we understand the
difference and how do we interpret that
difference but also we'll jump more into
the data mining aspect of this analysis
so not just looking at the difference
between what I understand my samples to
represent but being able to pull
together from different studies
leveraging the online the public domain
resources that are out there leveraging
maybe some were older experiments and
combining them with the newer
experiments and knowing how to operate
with these different more complex data
sets we can mine use these data mining
techniques and extract some meaningful
information and then use it for our next
steps we are assuming that the majority
of you already know some of these basic
things so you know what is biographer
Mattox you know that there are different
methods to analyze many different types
of data and not
generation sequencing but a lot of other
types of biological data you are
familiar with interpretation of that
data how we can leverage online
resources and databases and you already
have good experience of posing a
question that could be answered with a
specific type of data and you understand
how to kind of develop that question
based on new data that you have if you
don't we that's okay and that's even
maybe good to kind of refresh our
understanding so really we've put
together a number of resources that you
can find on this link on Edie UT - bio
info and so in fact this program is
going to rely on a lot of materials that
are provided there they're covered there
in detail as a tutorial and I'll walk
you through today some of the aspects of
those materials and the resources that
we'll be utilizing
now it's going to be useful for several
reasons obviously it covers a lot of the
things that are written right here so
introduction to bioinformatics is a
course that will talk about what is
bioinformatics and some of the
applications of bioinformatics and then
we have a broad overview in a number of
types of data that you can analyze from
genomic data to transcriptomic data
metagenomic data other types of data and
we talked about some of these aspects
within the context of a project so in a
lot of these materials that is going to
be a project and of course thinking of
your own research project is very
helpful in the context of other projects
that people have been successful with
and so we leverage some of these public
domain datasets where you have experts
that have published good results in good
analysis approaches and we can kind of
build on that to develop a better
approach to our own data and our own
questions that we would like to use so
in the context of this program
we will have some resources that will
hopefully streamline our ability to
execute the analysis and plan the
analysis but also to understand the
analysis what are we doing why are we
doing it and how to do it better so one
of the aspects are going to be some
tools and methods and so we are going to
utilize you you will be able to utilize
of course you're not required to but you
will be able to utilize some of the
tools that we provide on the T bio info
platform that allows you to run several
different types of analyses and I think
that it will be useful to at least try
and understand how it can help
streamline that analysis the second
aspect of the resources are these online
tutorials that you can always in your
own time go and review they have been
put together specifically to address the
interests of the people that we have
interacted with over the past year or
year and a half and we are going to talk
about in these different tutorials
online you will be able to see how some
of the same principles of mapping
quality control statistical analysis
data mining apply to different types of
data and how you can leverage those same
types of methods to extract different
types of insights from the same data we
also have some prepared project examples
now the project examples are in the
project section I will show you in a
little bit where you can find them but
also some of these are on different
topics from oncology to infectious
diseases to agricultural aspects of
different data types and so what we
wanted to put together are some examples
that you can kind of build from finally
we want to establish a community so
we've been running these programs for
some time we have a sense of how people
kind of go through the materials and
eventually put
ideas from these online resources to use
in their own projects and what we have
found is that while there is this
temptation to kind of jump into you know
doing my own analysis I already know
what I'm doing I'm just going to run
this one pipeline it's always been a
show to kind of expand first of all your
horizons and kind of see how other
people have done this before how other
people are thinking about this and so
we've spent a substantial amount of time
looking at failed pipelines that did not
work or failed experiments that did not
produce any interesting biological
insights and trying to think together
with people how do we go back and make
sure that we plan it right and then
because we've planted we were able to
generate some interesting insights into
the problems that we were trying to
solve so I think that establishing that
community again because bioinformatics
is such an interdisciplinary field it's
so important to understand who else is
in the program how can we in interface
with them and we want to leverage the
online of course because a lot of these
lectures are going to be online we do
want to try and leverage this online
community so let me pause here and just
kind of show you where this is this
community is so you can see that this is
the link I am going to paste it in chat
to all of you and please take a look in
your chat and make sure that you can
access this page this is the blog post
that we've published about this and I
will just show you how to get so if you
can see my screen down here at the
bottom you can see that organizational
pages and this is going to be the page
where you should be able to register for
this program now the way to register if
you're not registered on the site you
will see here a price
and for you it's going to be free
because you're already registered
through Elbe Iran so just make sure that
you have an account if you are not
logged in right here you will see a
button called register or login and
registration is free you can use your
social media account or you can use your
email to register and once you have
registered please email us that you have
registered and we will add you to this
program so you can email to say heal and
time that file or you can email so what
we need is to know that you have
registered and then you can be added to
the members of this group where we will
post the materials and we will also be
able to share forums where we post
answers to questions or files that we
are going through in terms of analysis
so this is somewhere that we would like
to interact but also you will be able to
see who else is a part of this program
so for example Joomla here is from
Louisiana Tech and we have his profile
right here so you can see you know he
was a part of a similar program at
Louisiana Tech and you can kind of see
you know who he is what he has done
where is he now
etc so different things like this so
this is just to show you how this works
what else is on here there are some
basic information about the program that
you will be able to see so some of the
upcoming sessions you can see that we
plan to have another program on July 8th
like I mentioned just to kind of repeat
all of the things that we went through
today and build on that because we did
just send out the information very
recently and I know that not everybody
was able to join so we didn't want to
make sure that
we go through this again and then we
will have another session on July 22nd
I'll go into detail about these sessions
but you can kind of see the upcoming
events right here you can see that we
are posting some of the information
about today's meeting for example how to
join and you'll be able to do that here
we also have here forums that we will be
starting to post different answers to
questions or any other type of
information that we share throughout
course and you'll be able to see here
the progress so as members of the same
group we will be able to track how
people interact with online resources
how they interact with the tools and
that is an important quantitative area
for us to measure the activity address
any kinds of issues and then start to
interact one on one with each one of you
to help you develop a project or kind of
review your project and help get to some
results at the end of the program that
we have scheduled for the second week of
August so this is a little overview I'll
go into more detail again this session a
little bit later and we'll be able to
talk about it more in our next session
so just to kind of continue from here
and as I said we'll be using some of
these tools and methods that we've
provided for this program we have some
online training modules that you will be
able to access for during the program we
have some project examples and there's
this community aspect that you will be
able to join and I pasted the link the
chat so if you've seen that link and if
you have registered during this session
you can also do that just let me know so
we will try and add you all even during
this session if we can
now some of the other things that we'll
be talking about is of course we'll talk
about the t bio info platform that
allows you to process and analyze some
of these datasets we'll talk a little
bit about our studio how you can build
on that analysis and expand it and maybe
leverage some of the public domain tools
out there to visualize your data to
analyze your data but we'll also talk a
lot about public domain data and I think
it's very important for us to be aware
of the value that is out there a lot of
these raw data sets that just can inform
our analysis can inform our experiment
design can help us generate a good
hypothesis and I think that there's a
lot of these tools and we'll talk a
little bit about how to find data how to
narrow down the thousands of results
that you can get for practically any
topic that you are planning to study and
how to four different repositories they
will have different ways of actually
accessing the data so we'll kind of walk
you through some of those things the
online training so I do want to show you
here in a second how the online training
works so that everybody understands what
it is that we actually are referring to
by the online training so as I just
showed you the organizational page that
you just saw for the Louisiana
biomedical research network somewhere
bioinformatics program on the same site
there are a series of courses on
transcriptomics on RNA seek that will
particularly focus in this program but
also you're welcome to you some of the
other sections for example genomics
metagenomics epigenetics etc so some of
that data is explained in detail if
you're interested you can go through
those we'll take a look at that in a
second and a lot of them will have these
practical assignments that you can
practice and run through
number of project examples and building
that experience building that skill is
going to help kind of translate this
into something more impactful in your
own research and in your own project so
what is this online platform that I'm
talking about the online platform you
might have been familiar with a platform
from other sessions that we did before
from vrn basically it's a user friendly
interface for performing these different
types of analyses so the all the aspects
that we will cover including quality
control including pre-processing
including mapping and then statistical
analysis like differential gene
expression quantification also using
different normalization techniques data
mining techniques a lot of that is going
to be available here but it's not a
closed platform it is really a platform
that helps you identify best methods and
best practices and then you can read
about the individual methods used and
utilize those methods in any environment
and so of course a lot of these methods
are already available on the HPC cluster
at the CCT and also in other places so
this is going to be our training and you
can see here that it covers many
different types of data from
next-generation sequencing data to mass
spec data structural biology data and
then it has some sections right here on
integration data mining some utilities
for annotation and interpretation of the
data but also some more kind of
domain-specific methods for example in
biology there's a number of different
sections so the benefit here of the
platform is really because it's a known
thing if you just type in bioinformatics
headache on Twitter you'll find a lot of
sentiment out there that unfortunately
comes with a
a lot of open source public domain great
resources but the problem is that they
either just work on the computer that
the developer developed them in or they
just work for the data that you know
that team is interested in and they come
up with a lot of interesting ideas and
interesting ways of analyzing this
next-generation sequencing data however
it's always straightforward to transfer
that from a publication where they
publish the code or you know some kind
of an online server to incorporate it
into your own analysis and so that's one
of the things that we wanted to address
in this platform we wanted to
standardize how these different tools
work so that they work with the same
type of input or it's clear what type of
input is needed they have some settings
that you are able to play with and adapt
the analysis to your own to your own
problem and they have a consistent
interface right so at least in a short
period of time you can try out many
different things now I also found on
Twitter there's an interesting kind of
step by step process of how typically
one would take a public domain algorithm
or a method published and how to kind of
walk through using that method so I have
that pasted right here
right one you see a tweet about this new
publish tool read the abstract sounds
exactly like what you're looking for I'm
going to just take this data and get a
perfect visualization of it then first
thing you typically find no link to the
source code but you can google around
and finally you find it you have to
compile and install it okay then you
have some library missing or your
version of R is outdated or some other
problem that you haven't accounted for
you have to Google around and spend a
lot of time to get it working run it on
some tiny data set that you prepared get
some kind of an error that is very
difficult to interpret right and then
you delete that whole package and never
visit it again so this is kind of like I
think an anecdotal of course example but
still I think true in many different
cases and that's part of the reason why
we first of all made sure that the tools
that we have work in some consistent way
but also in a way that we can interpret
so we understand what is it that we are
doing now that's why I think it's also
equally important equally critical for
us to understand how to use this data
and understand every step of the way and
that's what we want to focus on here so
what we are doing is we're going to be
focused on transcriptomics and so we
have a transcriptomics package so to say
a collection of courses that we hope all
of you would benefit from they start
from transcriptomics one and go all the
way to transcriptomics four so
transcriptomics one is the basics of
next generation sequencing
transcriptomics four is single-cell RNA
seek so it goes through four different
stages to kind of introduce everybody to
typical methods in bulk RNA seek all the
way to single cell and we will utilize
those in our program for this summer so
today we are having our kickoff workshop
that we will repeat again next week July
8th and then we'll be able to send you
this information in advance and make
sure that everybody's registered
everybody has their updated profile
information
everybody has submitted any information
that we need to start working on these
project ideas then we will offer these
optional online tutorials that we hope
that you will all complete and every
time that you complete this online
tutorial you get points and so you have
to get to a certain number of points to
be able to analyze your own data so the
idea is that we've worked with a lot of
people that again come to the problem of
analysis understanding how the
would do it from maybe past experience
or what they've read in online
literature etc and a lot of times some
of those things are not accurate and
they kind of would benefit from an
expanded overview of some of the basics
so those are the things that we put
together and every time that you
complete the online material you get a
number of points every time that you
complete an online assignment a
practical assignment you also get a
number of points at the end of this
process which we think could be
completed in anywhere between two and
four weeks you get sufficient amount of
points to join our transcriptomics
workshop in that workshop we will work
together with you to actually
practically build some pipelines run
them analyze the results and look at
what comes out and how to interpret it
and then you will be prepared both from
a theoretical standpoint in a practical
experience standpoint to plan your own
project and this session that we will do
in that workshop is also trying to see
where some of the challenges are coming
up is it in the planning stage is it in
collecting the right data is it in
adapting some kind of a pipeline
specifically to the type of problems
that you see in your data is it just
being stuck at some point of that right
so we will try to push through some of
those things and get everybody started
with their own analysis and then we will
have some time until our hats on and so
the idea behind the hackathon I mean we
can really view it as a workshop as the
hackathon it doesn't really matter what
we want to do is we want to make sure
that everybody can come together and
discuss some of these challenges that
they are facing but not just in the
context of I am facing a challenge and
you know what would be a way to address
it but let's address it together let's
get through this let's solve this
problem let's get it done let's get to a
point where you can talk about your
project your analysis your results and
that would be the
hackathon that is planned for August 9th
we'll do that at the CCT and we hope
that all of you that are going to be
working on your own independent project
will be able to come there and kind of
bring everything to a close that you
already feel good about it and then we
like we did last year for those that
have a good project and have made
progress you will have some more time
between the end of the program and the
annual bioinformatics conference where
you would be able to submit your
abstract and be considered for a poster
presentation and so that is really the
plan is to help you get something out of
your own project data get it analyzed
and presented and get some feedback and
so in in between those to the end of the
program and the conference will be able
to discuss with you one-on-one or in
groups how to make it better and how to
make an impactful presentation if that
is needed so again just to kind of go
through some of the dates today we are
in July first so we are having we had
originally planned a much longer session
to have it between 10:00 and 1:00 but
we're going to cut it short today
because we realized that we only sent
the information last night so not
everybody was able to join and we would
really love to go through all of this
together once again make sure that
everybody has this information so we
will try and do this again July 8th so
after this session we'll send out this
information again how to join we hope
that by that time everybody is already
registered on the site and we can see
everybody's profiles completed as much
as possible you're of course welcome to
if you're not familiar with a lot of
bioinformatics kind of general concepts
please try to go through the
introduction to bioinformatics module
and then we will start going into the
transcriptomics stuff but also we'll be
asking you to submit your project
yeah proposal data whatever you have
whatever stage you're at with your own
project I know that some of you already
have significant data sets assembled and
so we'll start going through okay how do
we upload this to the server how do we
start the analysis you know if it if
you're at some stage of their analysis
how do we review every stage and
document that stage so that we know what
has been done to the data already so
between July 8th and July 22nd which is
about two weeks we will try to make sure
that everybody completes the online
modules transcriptomics one two and
three are really kind of the basic
requirement to go through once you go
through those courses online courses
plus the information plus the points
that you get from the practical aspect
of things we should get you to about
2,000 points at minimum right and so
when you get to that 2,000 point mark
that's when you're ready to go into your
own independent project and when you do
your independent project you will get
access to a research user on the
research platform that means that you
can upload your own data we'll show you
how to upload your own data and start
running several analyses and kind of
keep track of your analyses to make sure
that you understand what those analyses
are because ultimately what you want to
do is complete an analysis but also have
that understanding how to conduct this
analysis so that you can reproduce it
and you know replicate it if needed in
the future and then August 9th which is
another couple of weeks after that July
session again we will have this
hackathon which at that time we will
hope to address any issues that are
coming up and really making sure that
you are not just kind of in the process
of analysis
you're really finalizing your analysis
you're at a stage where you're ready to
talk about it and hopefully every team
or every person that is participating in
this program will be able to share at
least something about the projects that
they are working on so at least this is
how we are thinking about this right now
again you're free to contact us and and
send us information about where you are
in this whole process and if you need
any additional help we'll be ready to
help you there for those of you at LSU
in Baton Rouge of course you're all
familiar with the CCT and there's a
whole team there that helps maintain
some of these sessions and John for
example cubed ou is with us on the call
and we'll be able to kind of monitor how
everybody is doing and making sure if we
know the information right if you tell
us we'll be able to address that so John
said in in chat right there hello
so please I think we'll you'll see
contact information kind of popping up
in some of our emails
okay so again what will we cover in
these sessions I just want to go a
little bit more in detail but before we
do that I do want to stop talking for a
moment because I have been talking a lot
and make sure that you know there's
anything any questions that you might
have anything you would like to ask or
add at this point you can unmute your
microphone and let us know and that
would be very helpful
so again I'm just pausing really quickly
here to let you ask any questions or
interrupt me here to say anything that
you would like if you want to just
introduce yourself and you know maybe
tell us a little bit about yourself
that's also fine so you can feel free to
unmute your mic so I'll just go ahead
and say hello to everyone I'm the
computer manager they'll be our in if
you all haven't met me I'm providing
support from the elber inside but mostly
I help people connect together between
Elia and Sahil and our group over here
although Elia already has a close
relationship with our group so I know
that they communicate all the time so
just hello everyone hello Joan thank you
yeah a lot of people are shy to speak up
remotely you all have a way of
communicating via the forums and stuff
like that
if they're new to that that's always a
great way to follow up with questions
and you think oh I should have asked
this question when he asked but I
forgotten whatever so just encourage
everyone to interact with he lien-tsai
heel in the forums if not directly
through these sessions all right thank
you and yeah please don't feel shy I
mean we are a small group today we hope
that next time everybody will join and
we'll we will have a chance to hear from
a lot of you a little bit about your
background I mean it could be as simple
as hey my name is Ilya this is what I am
doing right now and this is what I plan
to get out of this program and so again
I'll just give that opportunity again if
you would like to say a few words
hello yeah hello hi I'm Anne Ave Hyatt
I'm in the 2019 elgrand summer research
program so I've been doing a lot of
basic science research for my project
involving prostate cancer so the second
phase of my project I'm hoping to look
at some of these computational biology
techniques to see how I can further my
research great thank you and where are
you at LSU right now where are you okay
so I'm I'm a graduate student at LSU s
and I'm doing research at the Health
Science Center LSU Health Science Center
great thank you
alright well we got one person to share
and thank unify sorry if I mispronounced
your name there but you know we're
excited to have everybody here and again
sorry for the late notice about this
event but hopefully after this little
introduction you get a sense of where we
are as a group and by next time when
everybody joins we'll be able to do this
again so now I just want to quickly go
through some of the topics that we will
try to cover in these different sessions
next time July 8th after all of us have
a great time on July 4th we will go into
more detail with some basics about RNA
seek and here we'll start talking about
how do I find the data what types of
data are there out there that represents
RNA seek or next generation sequencing
data in fast queue or fast a format some
of you will be able to maybe find some
microarray data maybe we can look at
TCGA for example the Cancer Genome Atlas
where you can find already processed
data for you know with easy access so
some some of those resources we'll just
take a look at what's out there we'll
see how to download that data where to
put it how big should it be and when we
see the size how do we kind of
understand what the size represents what
type of sequencing or maybe what stage
of processing this would be and we will
see how to upload that data to the
server so that you understand the
process now we'll also review in detail
what is covered in the online
transcriptomics 1 and 2 so
transcriptomics 1 and 2 are these online
courses and I will show you here in a
second where you can find some of the
basics about what is next-generation
sequencing how to process from raw
sequencing files into a table of
expression and then how to work with
that table of expression to start infer
some information
that we can interpret biologically or
biomedically so that will happen in our
next session July 8th
then later on we will have a workshop on
July 22nd and in that workshop we want
to be able to go through a lot of the
aspects of transportation 2 & 3 as well
as talk about some other sides of
transcriptomic data analysis that maybe
isn't directly related to mrna or gene
expression we'll talk about some other
types of information we can get out of
these files for example micro RNA or
long non-coding RNA expression or
analysis of RNA editing how you can see
alternative splicing and other types of
events and compare them between groups
of samples or different conditions and
we'll talk a little bit about how to
take the data that we have in the table
maybe some information about ensembl IDs
or some kind of reference information
and transform that into something we can
understand from a biological standpoint
so those are some of the things that we
will cover in the workshop and then as I
said in August ninth you will see an
invitation to attend the hackathon we
hope to make this an in-person
experience because we think that you
know we'll be able to address
everybody's questions and problems
quickly together but it will be also
available to join remotely so obviously
you'll be able to kind of see what we're
doing some of us are doing and see some
of the presentations and also work
through your own problems online so
these are some of the events that we are
planning and as I mentioned already in
the meantime between now and some of
these events we are really hoping that
you can join the online environment
where we can track your progress and
help address any problems but
so that you are more aware of some of
the standard tools standard processing
tools that we have and start
understanding what goes into the
processing of this data so again I want
to go back to this organizational page
so right here at the bottom you can see
the link and I'll go to this link right
now so I'll you know transfer here and
just want to show you first of all you
have to be registered on the platform to
get gained access here right so you
should be able to see your account
information right here you can go to
your profile and you can see the courses
that you have enrolled in and here
you'll be able to see some of the
updates that we post and some of the
dates of our future events and of course
you can register in these events and
you'll be able to see the forum topics
that we will be addressing any kinds of
questions I mean we haven't really
posted anything here yet but we will
after this session so you can be able to
see some of the topics and links and
things like that we have a progress
section again I mentioned that everybody
has points so I'll show you in a second
how that works and you can also see the
curriculum so the curriculum will try to
address kind of will add this more in
detail what are the topics that we will
plan to review in this whole program
under here under assignments we will put
practical things that you know you would
benefit from doing for example right now
one of the things that we would like to
hear from everybody is about your
independent project so the independent
project is really the focus of this
program and at different stages
depending on where you are in your own
research you will get a sense of what is
the problem statement about what you're
trying to solve so for example prostate
cancer right
so prostate cancer is a very general
topic right we can now narrow it down
and talk about okay so maybe stages
right so stage maybe something like mRNA
expression changes by stage of prostate
cancer okay so I came up with some idea
and now I need to expand on that and say
okay what am I trying to do maybe I'm
looking at expression of different types
of genes or different transcripts in my
data and I want to understand that
change in the context of stage
progression of prostate cancer and then
I'll find some raw data that I'll have
to find the link for that data and maybe
some reference publications that I've
reviewed about this data if you are
working with API of your lab a professor
you're working with somebody else you
can mention that person here if you
generated your own data you would want
to put the experimental person who
designed the experiment in here just so
that we have that contact and if you
sequence the data in at a lab you want
to just put down okay which lab was this
if this is a public domain data set a
lot of this information is going to be
in the publication so it's still nice to
have that as a reference so that would
be you will see different assignments
come up here under here you will see the
courses the courses that are included in
this program and they're going to be
some of these basic courses online so
you can see introduction to
bioinformatics transcriptomics one two
transcriptomics three four and then we
have genomics one and two and of course
some of the other courses are going to
be available to you as well we have
other courses that you can see right
here and those include introduction to
bioinformatics machine learning genomics
epigenomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics and we are constantly
working on additional courses and also
you will have access to some project
and you can see some of the project
examples right here where if you see
something relevant to what you're trying
to study would be beneficial to kind of
go through that so this is these are the
materials again if you are registered as
a part of this program on this link that
I just gave I'm just going to give that
to you here again you will be able to
get access to all of this okay so also
you will be able to see some of the
other members as I mentioned a lot of
this is going to be you if you're trying
to you know let's say on project 1 and
sorry I microphone being on so again if
you could just turn it off for now ok so
about okay thank you
so about the profiles so here's an
example profile I already mentioned this
before but it's useful to kind of see
where people are and they mentioned
points the reason why we are putting
everything together is because it helps
us track where people are and try to
address the problems at that stage so
you can see that
chumma for example from Louisiana Tech
has a lot of points already over 9000
points and you can actually see some of
the types of things that he is doing and
now because we are in the same group yes
and we'd stop I'm going to address this
question about software so you will see
that for example he started the pipeline
on server T bio info right and so if you
go there this is actually the account
that you you will have to request after
you register on the edu side you will
have to request an account and you will
get that account and once you're there
you'll see that
you also have an account here and this
these two accounts are going to be
linked and they're gonna be linked in
the sense that you will be able to see
your progress on your account over here
and I will show you what that would look
like on my account so for example as you
saw I have this account right and you
can see that all of the activity from my
account and sometimes you can see for
example I worked on some pipeline so I
will see that this pipeline has been
finished and if I click on that link it
will take me to that specific pipeline
that I ran and so it's again important
and we'll go through in detail what is
all available on this platform in terms
of different types of analysis that you
can run how to upload data to be able to
run it here how to download the data how
to download some of the scripts if you
would like to modify those scripts
further etc so this is just to give you
an overview again ok so that was the
organizational page and we covered the
form that you can use to start
submitting your projects that we can
consider for the project so if you don't
have your own project these are some of
the projects that we have have that you
can start with to kind of get a sense of
what could be done and where this can go
so we put those in terms of where the
data is located what is the reason we're
using specific types of analyses and
what is the output how do we interpret
it and how do we use it and we'll also
kind of work with you to prepare these
individual projects that you're working
on whether they're from public domain or
they are from your own lab where you
generated this and how to present the
data and explain the analysis that you
did so that's going to be a part of what
we do and we've done this before and we
think that a lot of people actually
learn from that experience then the
even more than the online materials and
workshops like this together people
actually learn a lot when you try to
apply these ideas to your own challenges
like I said we're going to be able to
review how to either enrich the project
that you're already working with with
some of the public domain data maybe
working with public domain data will
give you a sense of where to take your
own analysis what things are possible
and we will give you some examples so
we'll do in our workshop for earn July
22nd will kind of walk through some of
those examples and here you can see an
example of how to find the data to a
specific question that you might have
now we also want to be sure that we
understand how all of you are making
progress and so what we want to collect
our pre and post-assessment surveys
where we would require a little bit of
time from you to read a publication
answer some questions about the
publication so that jointly you for
yourself can evaluate how well you
understand some of these figures that
are typically published in in standard
publications that utilize this kind of
data and we can understand whether some
of the materials that we have provided
are helping you get get more out of
these types of things so again what we
will use are some public some
publication data so data sets that have
been referenced in a publication and
we'll try to find something that kind of
fits everybody's interest and whether
it's oncology or other other projects
will share that by next time and then we
will try and compare the before and
after right how well do we understand it
before the program how has that changed
for after the program and a lot of times
what we see is a lot of improvement even
for faculty and researchers and I think
that plays
huge role in your ability to them
independently develop these projects and
analyze the data so again I am excited
about seeing everybody in our next
session that's going to be a little bit
longer and we'll kind of skip a lot of
these technical things to jump into a
little bit more about RNA seek and what
you can do with this type of data we'll
talk about different types of data that
are included in you know that are vary
by the type of method you used for to
prepare the data and so these are some
of the things that we will cover we will
cover kind of the different data types
that can come from next-generation
sequencing and what are the results of
that analysis typically included in RNA
seek we'll also talk about different
file formats and we'll talk about how we
can use the information in these
different large data sets like fast
queue format and the FASTA format in the
GTF format and what other information is
needed to process this data and to give
us some biologically interpretable
result and we'll also talk about some of
the other things that are not just gene
expression right so we'll talk about the
same principles that we use in RNA
sequencing you know how do they vary
between next generation sequencing like
an Illumina sequencer how do we
interpret the same type of information
coming from microarrays how do we use
different library preparation techniques
like chromatin immunoprecipitation how
do we look at other events like RNA
editing etc so we will try and kind of
give a broad introduction next time and
then hopefully utilizing the online
materials you will be able to start
generating some kind of a table and once
you have a table one of the problems is
that it's really counterintuitive so
it's not as simple as ok so I have these
three genes and you know in this
condition in that condition I can easily
understand the variation a lot of times
this data is very
flex and counterintuitive and there's a
lot of internal variation that you
somehow need to mine for some insights
relevant to what you're trying to
question so we are going to talk about
some of those data mining approaches as
well and again I want to kind of
conclude this session by asking you to
register on the site start looking at
some of these online materials and
especially if you can go this is the
link where you can see the
transcriptomics can collection of course
and so you can see transcriptomics one
two three and four starting from the
very basics of what a lot of that we
will cover in our next session and all
the way to single cell which of course
this might take a little bit longer time
but still you know it might be relevant
to some of you so the link is right here
in the chat you can start looking at
that and hopefully next time we'll have
a little more time and everybody will be
able to draw and so we'll review some of
the stuff see where people are at and
kind of started talking about some of
these projects so that's all I had for
today I wonder if you have any questions
this would be a good opportunity you can
either add those questions in the chat
and I'll just read through them and be
able to answer right now or if you have
any questions you can unmute and I'll
answer
all right well in that case um again
I'll just paste this link so you will be
able to actually register just on this
link right here yep and then you will be
added to you um to here again if you can
email us then you will be getting added
to the program and we'll be able to keep
track from there how how to get the most
out of this program so again thank you
everyone for joining today and I look
forward to meeting you next session
which will be in on July yes so
essentially once you register to this
whole organization page right so first
you have to register to the site then
you will have an account and then you
will be able to register to all of those
events again at first when you register
and you go here you will see this price
once you're a part of this group it's
not going to be there anymore so you'll
be able to register to all the events
for free and of course get access to all
of this information and see that you are
a part of this group right here on the
activity page so you can see once I'm
registered you see that you will say
that my membership expires September
30th and then yes you can register the
advance to each individual event or you
can register to all of us right there
yes the price will disappear once you
are registered
all right thank you everyone and hope to
see you again next time